CHRIS: It's my distinct pleasure
to welcome Professor Paul
Sabin who is an environmental
and energy historian at Yale.
It's my distinct pleasure to
welcome him to Google so please
join me in giving him
a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
PAUL SABIN: Thanks, Chris.
And thanks for having
me here at Google.
Americans love history, but
I think in this business
and technology
setting, it's worth
asking what history is good for.
And I want to emphasize
a couple of things
in starting out around that.
One is just the way
that history can
help us to appreciate complexity
and the uncertainty of the past
and also the way in which
it can help us to develop
a way that we can cultivate
empathy for the people whose
lives we're studying and
whose decisions and choices
we're trying to understand.
I think these two different
kinds of understanding
can help us cultivate
our listening,
can foster a critical
sense of humility,
and also they can
raise questions for us
to ask about the future.
More generally, I
think that history
can offer a sense of
context and perspective
that's necessary for the
challenging social choices
that I believe we have
to make in charting
our future on the planet.
Now, science and technology
and economics obviously all
have a critical role
to play in this future.
But I think that they
don't have all the answers.
And they don't
necessarily even prepare
us to know what
questions to ask.
So that's where I think history
can play a critical role.
So I want to circle
back to these themes
at the close of my talk,
to talk a little bit
about the interesting
and complex ways in which
the story that I'm
going to share today
has been interpreted and the
way people have reacted to--
and let me just say
I guess as a hint
that listening and humility
are not the keywords that
come to mind in thinking
about that interpretation.
So today I want to
tell you a story based
on my recent book, "The Bet:
Paul Ehrlich, Julian Simon,
and Our Gamble Over
Earth's Future."
And my goal is
really to provide you
with some perspective on the
growing partisanship that
has come to engulf our debate
over environmental issues
in the United States.
And this is really
to help us also
think more about risks of
environmental catastrophe
and resource scarcity
on the one hand
and also the promise of
technological innovation
and human ingenuity and
progress, human advancement
into the future.
So this is a story about
sharply disagreeing viewpoints.
But as I'll say at the
end, I think the challenge
for us really is
to try to find ways
to reconcile these different
viewpoints and learn from them.
Now, we weren't always as
divided as we are today.
Just this week, you had the
Senate Democrats pulling
an all nighter to talk
about climate issues,
and on the other side,
you have many Republicans
who are questioning whether
climate change is caused
by humans or to what extent
it's changing and opposing
many of the initiatives that
EPA-- a job-killing agency
it's been called.
So we weren't always
as divided as this,
and I think it's
worth going back
to remember some of the
bipartisanship with which
the environmental legislation
of the 1970s was passed.
The Clean Air Act,
the Clean Water Act,
the National Environmental
Policy Act, all of these
were passed with bipartisan
support in Congress.
And Richard Nixon
actually articulated
this bipartisan attitude in
his 1970 state of the union.
And I wanted to
share, if I can here,
a little video from
him in which he talks
about how a concern
for the environment
was something that
should be beyond party
and beyond faction.
So this is Richard Nixon
talking in the 1970s
state of the union.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-The great question
to the '70s is,
shall we surrender
to our surroundings
or shall we make our
peace with nature
and begin to make reparations
for the damage we have done
to our air, to our
land, and to our water?
[APPLAUSE]
Restoring nature to
it's natural state
is a cause beyond party
and beyond factions.
It has become a common cause of
all the people of this country.
It is a cause of particular
concern to young Americans
because they more than we will
reap the grim consequences
of our failure to act on
programs which are needed now
if we are to prevent
disaster later.
Clean air, clean
water, open spaces,
these should once again--
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
PAUL SABIN: So this is Nixon
with a unifying message,
bringing people together
around the environment.
And he didn't necessarily stay
in this point of view for long.
He became a little
disillusioned with how well
the environmental cause was
serving him politically.
And he wasn't necessarily a
passionate environmentalist.
Here's a picture of him
walking on the beach.
He was trying to
be Kennedy-esque
walking on the beach
in Southern California
but with his wing tip
shoes and his dress pants.
But still, even Nixon was
bringing people together
around the environment.
And so that was in the early
1970s, but by the 1980s,
you had a gradually
growing division,
greater partisanship
around the environment.
And you can see that in these
League of Conservation scores
by chamber and party.
You can see kind of a gradually
opening gulf between the two
parties on the votes
that they were cataloging
in Congress for this index.
So what are the explanations
for this growing partisanship
around the environment?
There are several
common explanations.
Some have explained it in part
as the sifting out of the two
parties by region and
according to ideology,
where the Southern
Democrats moved over
to the Republican Party and
the northern Republicans
moved over to the
Democrat and kind of took
their environmental
affiliations with them.
Others have explained it as
more of a business backlash,
with business interests
fighting regulation and pushing
their political allies to
contest regulatory initiatives.
And still others have identified
a conservative intellectual
revolution with think
tanks and funding
for public intellectuals
who would then
advance criticism of
environmental regulation.
I think all of these
different explanations
have some truth to them.
And scholars have
examined them in depth.
But at the same time, I think
that these interpretations
don't say the whole story.
And what I want to explore
today is the genuine clash
that occurred between different
viewpoints in the 1970s
and 1980s because these
interpretations really
explain the growing
partisanship primarily
as just a political and economic
development, that people are
representing their political
and economic interest.
And they tend not
to look more closely
at the intellectual
conflicts and what
I see as some of the
weaknesses and flaws
of the environmental
movement during this period.
So I think that's a mistake.
And in my book, "The
Bet," I revisit the rise
of the environmental
movement since the 1960s
and the backlash and the
debates that it engendered.
And so I approach this story
through a smaller story
that I think allows entry into
the larger debates happening
in environmental politics.
And this was a story about the
biologist Paul Ehrlich, here
on your left, author of the
1968 book "The Population Bomb,"
and his antagonist Julian
Simon on the right,
who wrote the book "The
Ultimate Resource."
And these two men
made an actual bet,
which is a rare thing in
intellectual disagreements.
They came together around a
bet over metal prices in 1980.
And it was a simple bet over
five metals, chromium, copper,
tin, nickel, and tungsten.
It was a bundle of those
metals worth a total of $1,000.
And, essentially,
if the prices rose,
Simon would pay the difference
and if the prices fell,
Ehrlich and his
colleagues would pay.
And it was going to
be a 10 year bet.
Now, it was a simple
bet about metal prices,
but really the bet
stood for much more.
It was really a proxy
for their competing
visions of the future.
On Ehrlich's side, an
apocalyptic vision that
was fearful about human
excess and over population.
And on Simon's side,
optimistic and bullish
about the potential
for human progress.
Ehrlich thought that
rising metal prices
would signify that population
growth caused resource
scarcity.
And that would bolster his call
for government-led population
control and limits
on consumption.
Simon argued that markets
and new technology
would drive prices down.
And this would prove
that society did not
face resource constraints and
that human welfare, in fact,
was going to steadily improve.
And so the outcome of the
small bet about metal prices
would have these tremendous
implications for what direction
the planet and
humanity was headed in.
It would either
bolster Ehrlich's call
for limits on population
growth and his warnings
of an environmental calamity.
Or it would fuel
Simon's attack on what
he called Ehrlich's
"unfounded threats of doom."
So in the book I try, in
the spirit of the empathy
that I talked about and
the complexity, to explore
these two men and
their different lives
and how they arrived at the
positions that they took.
And I want to talk a
little bit about that
because Ehrlich
and Simon actually
are very interesting characters
who shared much in common.
Actually, in some ways,
that was what drove them,
I think, to such
sharp disagreement.
They both were born in 1932
to Jewish families that
were based originally
in the cities,
in Philadelphia and in
Newark, but then moved out
into the suburbs
just before they
each were around 10 years old.
And they actually
grew up about three,
five miles apart from
each other in Maplewood,
and Millburn, New Jersey.
Ehrlich was a child of
the suburbs in the sense
that he loved chasing
butterflies through the fields
and he was impassioned about
the threat of development
to the suburban landscape.
He became early on
concerned about the danger
of DDT, the pesticide being
sprayed that was endangering
the food sources that he wanted
to feed to his butterflies.
He was a lover of nature.
At one point, he had so many
aquariums and other types
of collections in
his bedroom that he
had to move out and
move up into the attic
to make room for them.
So Ehrlich's study
of butterflies,
which he's continued as
a professor up the road
here at Stanford-- this
is the Bay Checkerspot
butterfly-- really
provided him with a model
for thinking about
human population growth
because he studied the rise and
fall of butterfly populations
in relationship to the abundance
and scarcity of resources.
And so, in seeing that
butterfly populations might grow
and then they might outstrip the
resources that were available
and then they would crash in
this tremendous collapse--
and then he said this
was the same thing that
was going to happen to people.
And so he predicted the greatest
cataclysm in the history of man
was coming, this
population collapse
that would be caused by food
shortages, disease outbreaks,
maybe thermonuclear war.
And he described
that the population
had grown to the
extent-- he said
we've had most of what he called
the outbreak of population
and now all that
we're waiting for is
what's going to
come in the crash.
So kind of basically modeling
onto human populations
the same developments
as with butterflies
and other creatures.
And he wasn't alone in this.
There were many biologists
in the post World War Ii
period who were thinking about
animal populations in this way.
Ehrlich was so concerned about
the threat of population growth
that he came to embrace
the idea of triage,
that some countries
might be so far gone,
so headed directly
towards catastrophe
and unable to feed themselves
that they should actually
be cut off from food aid.
And he put countries like
India in this category,
saying the US should
no longer send them
food aid because quote,
"dispassionate analysis
indicates that the unbalance
between food and population
is hopeless."
And he argued that the optimum
human worldwide population
was somewhere between 600
million and 1.5 billion people,
so significantly less than what
even the population was then
around 1968, 1970.
Now, Ehrlich was a very
popular, charismatic speaker
with a biting wit,
very entertaining.
Here he is speaking to students
around Earth Day at Iowa State
University.
He spoke to audiences
of thousands.
And in 1970, he
really became famous
after Johnny Carson invited
him onto "The Tonight Show,"
became a big fan of his,
loved having him on the show
and had him actually
more than 20 times
onto "The Tonight
Show" and really shared
a lot of his views on population
and environmental issues
and gave him that platform.
That really brought Ehrlich
to much greater fame.
Now, Julian Simon,
as I said, also
grew up in suburban New
Jersey in his teenage years.
But his formative years
were really in Newark.
And he was impressed in
the early age the hustle
and bustle of immigrant life.
And he loved the
diversity of people
and the excitement
of being in the city,
and he always,
after he moved out
into the suburbs-- he regretted
the loss of that community
that he had felt when
he had been in Newark.
And I think that carried through
in his appreciation of cities
and people and more people
bringing more excitement
and diversity to the world.
He took a slightly more
circuitous path into academia.
Here he is as a Boy
Scout as a young boy.
He served in the Navy
for a few years also,
giving him an impression
of what the world was like.
And what he saw
later would describe
some of the more rundown
areas of the world
where his Navy ship
would stop and thinking
about how they had improved
over time, that you didn't just
see the beautiful
parts of the world
but there were
these other places
that he had seen and saw the
improvements that took place
there.
Now, Simon early on actually
shared Ehrlich's view
about the threat of
population growth.
And he got into studying
marketing and business.
And he was hired by I
think it was the Population
Council to develop
marketing plans for family
planning in India
and in other places.
And so he was originally
trying to figure out
how to address the problem
of population growth.
But then he came to believe
that actually population growth
wasn't a problem.
And in this, he sort of linked
up with some other economists
at the time, people like Simon
Kuznets and Richard Easterlin.
And they had examined historical
patterns of economic growth
and correlated them
with population growth
and decided that
there wasn't actually
evidence that population
growth was diminishing
national economic growth.
And you also people like the
Danish agricultural economist
Ester Boserup, who found that
population growth actually
increased innovation in
agriculture and spurred saving.
And so rather than
agriculture setting limits
for population, which was
the idea that there was only
so much that
agriculture produced.
She actually found that it
was sort of the reverse.
It was the density and
the demand of population
that set limits on
agriculture and that the forms
of agriculture were determined,
in part, by population size
and density and that
it would stimulate
new kinds of
agricultural practices.
Now in 1980, Simon broke
out into the public arena
with a article in "Science"
in which he attacked
Ehrlich and other
doom-sayers for what he said
were unfounded-- the
oversupply of false bad news.
And he soon found common
cause with libertarians
and conservatives and
enjoyed a lot of attention
as a regular contributor
to op-ed pages
with these kinds of
arguments-- that life on Earth
is improving, that these
myths of overpopulation.
"Why Do We Think
Babies Create Poverty?"
So these are all
part of a campaign
to change the way that people
thought about population
growth, and he
then extended this
as well to the problem
of immigration.
And this is where actually--
these characters, these
are individual
intellectuals navigating
the currents of
American politics--
in which he sort of fell
out with many American
conservatives because
Simon actually
was quite pro-immigration,
believing that immigrants were
an asset to the American
economy and would
stimulate economic growth.
They took much less
than they contributed.
And so he was an early
advocate for immigration.
So actually there was
recently the suggestion
that Detroit should create
a special economic zone
and invite immigrants
to come in who
would invest to create
jobs in the city.
This was the kind of thing
that Simon was in favor of.
And actually just as
an aside, you may never
have heard of Julian
Simon before today,
but one of the things
that he's more known for--
or you would know
him for-- is that he
was one of the main advocates
for the idea of an auction
for overbooking on airlines,
that you should have a market.
So if you have ever been
bumped from a flight
and gotten a free flight or
some other benefit as a result,
that was one of the ideas that
Julian Simon was an advocate
for.
So if Simon sort of fell
out with conservatives
over his position
on immigration,
Ehrlich also had sort of
a complicated relationship
to liberals.
And he came under attack
for being racist, being
anti-immigrant, those
types of questions
about what was his position.
And actually during
the 1970s, he
spent a fair amount of his
time trying to defend himself
and to make the
case that there was
a rational basis for his
ideas about population control
and also control of immigration.
So these are two books that
he published during the '70s.
One, "The Race Bomb," which
basically said that race is,
from a biological perspective,
not a meaningful category.
And so we shouldn't think
about racial differences.
And "The Golden
Door," which analyzed
Mexican-American relations
and made the case
that we shouldn't blame Mexican
immigrants but at the same time
there was still a rational
basis or rational reason
for wanting to
limit immigration.
So this was a lot
of his efforts was
trying to navigate those
complicated politics.
Now, I wanted to give you
a bit of a taste of Ehrlich
and Simon.
If it will work, I have
a little video here
to share just to give
you a bit of a sense
of their rhetorical styles
and some of their arguments.
So this is Ehrlich
in 1971, I believe,
on an Australian television
show called "Monday Conference."
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I wonder if we could
begin at the end in a way.
One of the things that
Dr. Ehrlich is saying
is that things are so bad
that people should not
be allowed to have as many
children as they may now want.
What do we think of this?
Does anyone have a
comment on that or--
-While I'm very intrigued
by Dr. Ehrlich's concern
for the environment,
for our future,
I'm quite appalled at the
"1984" style of society
that he postulates in his books.
He would seem to cut right
across inalienable human rights
and demand that people be
legalized to produce children.
He would tend to demand
that we limit our families
and, if people are
not willing to do this
by propaganda-- propaganda
principally aimed
at the impoverished people
and at the dark races--
he would introduce
legal sanctions.
Having introduced
legal sanctions,
what legal penalties
for those who
disobey the law of the
scientists, compulsory abortion
or imprisonment?
Well, let me first point out
that you have misrepresented
my views somewhat, although you
have come close in other areas.
Like, one of the
things that we have
to face very clearly is
the question, if we do not
solve this problem by finding
ways to change people's
attitudes, what
kinds of sanctions
might you impose that do
not bear differentially
on the poor or the black or
the nations in the world that
are underdeveloped and so on?
And this is an area where the
questions are very difficult.
And, actually, in many
ways, the best answer
from the point of
view of democracy
seems to be an
across-the-board limitation
of family size to two children
unless the second birth is
a multiple birth.
Now, you say these are
inalienable rights.
A favorite sport of people is
to make up inalienable rights
to fit their own preconceptions.
I say there's an
inalienable right
to have grandchildren
that you'll
abrogate if you have
too many children.
There's an inalienable
right to have clean air,
not to breathe poisons.
There's an inalienable right
to have natural beauty,
to have enough food,
and so on, and so forth.
now there was a time
when people thought
it was an inalienable right
to have the number of spouses
that they chose to have.
And certainly no government
could intervene on that,
but I believe the Australian
government intervenes on that
inalienable right and restricts
you to one spouse at a time
and throws you probably
right into jail if you don't.
So I suspect that
could easily happen
with the number of
children you have too.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
PAUL SABIN: So in addition
to the marvelous sideburns
that he is displaying
here, I think
there are another couple of
interesting elements of this.
You can see here the rhetoric.
We have to take action now
or disaster will come later.
And sort of a grandiose
vision of that--
you're going to abrogate your
right to have grandchildren
if we don't take action now.
So it's a very stark portrayal.
You can see, again,
this issue of him
trying to develop a rational
basis for population control,
defending against the
criticism that this might
be racist or
inequitable and trying
to create a fair way to
have population control.
And I think another
element there
that you can see here is just
the sharp rhetorical style,
the humor, the ability to
take convey the argument that
is quite compelling as
a presentation style.
Now, here Ehrlich is
sporting sideburns.
Here is Julian Simon
sporting his own flourish.
He liked to wear these
plastic devil horns sometimes
when he gave talks.
It was kind of a
provocation of his audience.
You portray me as the devil
with these terrible ideas
that I have and so I'm going
to stick it in your face
by wearing these devil horns.
I think it was also maybe a
bit of a defensive mechanism
that he used to protect himself.
But here he is laying
out his arguments
for why he thinks we don't face
a threat of resource scarcity
and why he thinks
things are just
going to keep on getting better.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Every trend in
material human welfare
has been getting better
rather than worse.
And as to the future, you
ask, would I bet on it?
The answer is, yes.
I will bet on it.
I make this offer to any
prominent doom-sayer.
You pick any measure of
material human welfare,
you pick any place in
the world, any country,
you pick any year in the
future, starting, say,
10 years from now so there's
time for things to happen,
and I'm prepared to bet that
that dimension that you pick,
that aspect of human
welfare you pick,
will show improvement relative
to now and not deterioration.
Now, before we go
on, let me give you
the theory of how this could
possibly happen in a nutshell.
And I'll repeat this
theory later on.
The theory goes like this.
You have more people,
you have higher income,
and that increases the
demand for resources.
Increased demand for resources
means higher prices, either
actual or expected.
Now that's as far as the
Malthusian theory goes,
but the economy
doesn't stop there.
What happens is
that these expected
higher prices
represent opportunity.
They represent
opportunity to businesses.
Businesses say,
aha, higher prices.
Greater opportunities
for profit.
I'll get to work and see
if I can find some way
to increase my supply or
find substitutes or whatever.
It also represents
opportunity for scientists,
who say, here's a chance for
me to make a discovery that
will help humanity, maybe
even get a Nobel Prize for it.
So that's the theory.
But one more bit.
So people go to work looking for
ways to fill this opportunity.
Most of them fail.
They don't find
solutions to the problem,
but they pay the
price themselves.
Eventually, some
people do succeed
in finding solutions
to these problems.
And the extraordinary part is
that the solutions that they
find leave us better off
than if the problem had not
arisen in the first place.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
PAUL SABIN: So this is
Simon's response to Ehrlich.
And some of this is some
basic economic theory,
ideas about technological
substitution, innovation,
the spur to investment, the
search for new resources.
You also can see,
in Simon, he has
some of the same
rhetorical style
as Ehrlich in the sense of
a kind of combativeness.
I'll bet you.
I'll challenge you.
A similar aggressiveness.
And also a tendency towards, not
just that things are generally
getting better, but an
extreme version of that
in which every
single thing is going
to be getting better
all across society.
So that's a portrayal of Simon.
And now I want to
turn now to what
I think is an interesting
element of the story.
So they make the bet in 1980.
And that's actually only one
of the bets that's in my book.
The second bet is the
other bet that the nation
was making in 1980 which was
the choice between Jimmy Carter
and Ronald Reagan in
the 1980 election.
I think in interesting
ways, the arguments
between Ehrlich and
Simon actually line up
in striking ways with the
division between Carter
and Reagan.
Now, Carter really brought
the Ehrlich perspective
into the White House
in a lot of ways.
He embraced the idea of
conservation and limits.
Here he is walking,
after his inauguration,
walking the distance
to the White House.
And here installing the
solar panels on a roof
in the White House.
And he talked about how,
even our great nation
has its recognized limits.
More is not necessarily better.
And he closely shared a lot of
the key philosophical elements,
I think, of the 1970s
environmental sensibility.
He had a passion for nature
as a child in Georgia.
He had fished and
hunted in the streams.
And, as governor, he had
protected a lot of open space
and tired to coordinate
regional planning
to be more rational
and more conserving.
He had a moral righteousness
that Ehrlich also has,
a moral righteousness
about the need
to address human excess
and human wastefulness.
And he had a conviction
that government planning
was the proper way to
respond and to address
social and
environmental planners.
And Carter actually got his
start with regional planning
initiatives in
Georgia, and he brought
this idea of planning
to the White House.
He approached these
problems as a planner.
So in this particular,
he was focused
on the problem of energy
in the late 1970s.
And he worried about how
the Americans were grossly
wasting our energy resources
and other materials
as though their
supply was infinite.
But we must face the
prospect of changing
our basic ways of living.
And he expressed
this in similar terms
to Ehrlich, saying,
"this change will either
be made in our own initiative
in a planned or rational way.
So that's Ehrlich's idea that
if you can take action now,
then we can avoid
problems in the future.
"Or changes will
inevitably," he said,
"be forced on us with
chaos and suffering
by the inexorable
laws of nature,"
And so I think this
aligns in a lot
of ways with Ehrlich's ideas.
And here, just to give you
a taste of Carter's take,
this is him talking about
energy in April '77, April 1977
speech addressed to the nation
on a proposed energy policy.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-The energy crisis has
not yet overwhelmed us,
but it will if we
do not act quickly.
It's a problem
that we will not be
able to solve in
the next few years.
And it's likely to get
progressively worse
through the rest
of this century.
We must not be
selfish or timid if we
hope to have a decent
world for our children
and our grandchildren.
We simply must balance
our demand for energy
with our rapidly
shrinking resources.
By acting now, we can
control our future
instead of letting
the future control us.
Two days from now, I will
present to the Congress
my energy proposals.
Its members will be my
partners and they have already
given me a great deal
of valuable advice.
Many of these proposals
will be unpopular.
Some will cause you to
put up with inconveniences
and to make sacrifices.
The most important thing
about these proposals
is that the alternative may
be a national catastrophe.
Further delay can affect
our strength and our power
as a nation.
Our decision about
energy will test
the character of
the American people
and the ability of the
president and the Congress
to govern this nation.
This difficult effort will
be the moral equivalent.
of war.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
PAUL SABIN: So this
is Carter warning
about national catastrophe.
He worried that the US
was going to run out
of oil reserves in the
1980s and that disaster
was right around the corner.
And this was sort of-- the
image that Carter presented
to the country
was one of limits,
of the need for
sacrifice, and the need
to address this with planning.
And that was something
that Ronald Reagan strongly
objected to and came in
resisting that, running
for office on the promise
of American greatness.
And he to a significant
extent, I think,
sang to the tune
of Julian Simon.
The idea that resource
limits weren't real,
that they wouldn't
constrain America's future.
And this announcement for his
candidacy for the White House--
I think it's striking
how much he focused
in terms of the rationale
for his candidacy
on the predictions that
the United States faced
limits and doom and constraints.
And I wanted to share with you
this clip from his announcement
of the candidacy in 1979.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Now there are those
in our land today,
however, who would have
us believe that the United
States, like other great
civilizations of the past,
has reached the
zenith of its power,
that we're weak and fearful,
reduced to bickering
with each other and no
longer possessed of the will
to cope with our problems.
Much of this talk
has come from leaders
who claim that our problems
are too difficult to handle.
We're supposed to meekly
accept their failures
as the most which
can humanly be done.
They tell us we must
learn to live with less
and teach our children that
their lives will be less
full and prosperous
than ours have been,
that the America
of the coming years
will be a place where,
because of our past excesses,
it will be impossible
to dream and make
those dreams come true.
I don't believe that, and I
don't believe you do either.
That's why I'm seeking
the presidency.
I cannot and will not stand
by and see this great country
destroy itself.
Our leaders attempt to blame
their failures on circumstances
beyond their control,
on false estimates
by unknown unidentifiable
experts who
rewrite modern
history in an attempt
to convince us our high
standard of living--
the result of thrift
and hard work--
is somehow selfish
extravagance which
we must renounce as we
join in sharing scarcity.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
PAUL SABIN: Now, Reagan doesn't
specify who these anonymous
experts are, but I would argue
that he's referring to people
like Paul Ehrlich and also the
authors of the 1972 book "The
Limits to Growth" who had
run these computer models
of resources and the economy
and population and said that--
in a similar story to
Ehrlich's-- that we were going
to have a population overshoot
and then a collapse more
or less right around
now or in another decade
or so in the 21st century.
So Reagan came in
and he used this
is new idea about how we
didn't face fundamental limits
or scarcity as a
rationale, a justification,
for regulatory relief.
He set up a vice presidential
commission on regulatory relief
and instructed the Office
of Management and Budget
to apply new tests
to try to do what
David Stockman, the head
of the budget office,
said was a regulatory
ventilation, was the language.
But the idea was really
to try to reversal
a lot of the regulations that
had been passed in the '70s.
And so the bipartisanship
era of environmental policy
was truly over at this point.
The environmental
groups attacked
Reagan and I think
the partisanship
that we have come to see
really settled in quite fully.
And it centered in some ways
I think on the questions that
were at the heart of the
Ehrlich and Simon bet
which is, does the
US, does the planet,
face an environmental crisis?
Were we running out of resources
and compelled to conserve?
And what were the natural
limits of American growth?
So in October
1990, Julian Simon,
having moved to Maryland,
picked up his mail and opened up
and there was a sheet
of metal prices in there
with a check for $576.07.
And there was no
note, but it was
clear the check was
from Paul Ehrlich
to settle the bet on the metals.
The metals fallen, on
average, by around 50%,
so Simon prevailing
across the board.
And it's interesting to think
about why that turned out
to be the case.
In part, it was the collapse
of oil prices after 1979,
but you also had all
these different kinds
of everyday market forces which
were the very kinds of things
that Simon and other
economists had talked about,
the substitution of new
technologies like fiber
optic cables and satellites
for copper wires,
the breakup of the
tin cartel, which
had propped up tin prices.
And when it collapsed, the
prices fell through the floor.
You had new sources
of supply that
were brought on because higher
prices stimulated people
to go out to search
for new mines.
You had the break up
of labor conflicts
that had sent prices
higher in the late '70s,
and then when those
conflicts were resolved,
prices went down.
So in all these
different ways, you
had these everyday market
forces, the kinds of things
that Simon had talked about.
But even more generally than
the prices of metal-- the thing
to note is the
worldwide population
had grown by 800 million
during this period,
from a from 4.5 to
5.3 billion people,
to date the largest
increase over a decade.
And yet the metal
prices had still fallen.
More broadly, in
thinking about the bet--
so the bet was a proxy for
a larger bet, which is,
what was going to be
the fate of humanity?
Measures of human
health and human wealth
also have increased over
time during that time period
and on up until the
present time as well.
I don't if any of you have
ever seen Hans Roslings
interesting videos about
human history in four minutes.
He has this great video in which
he explains the improvements
in health and wealth over the
last couple hundred years.
So at first glance, the results
of the Ehrlich Simon bet
seem to suggest a
simple story line.
There's a clear winner
and a clear loser.
And the bet itself quickly
became a symbolic weapon
in battles between
conservatives and liberals
over environmental
policy, saying, look,
Simon won this bet
so environmentalists
are wrong about this
and everything else.
And so this is the
reason for opposing
all different kinds
of regulation.
And so is it a symbol
of its symbolic value.
The Competitive Enterprise
Institute, for instance,
today awards a Julian
Simon award for someone
who is contributing to our
appreciation of the powers
of human ingenuity
and innovation.
And the award is
a leaf-- I'm not
sure what the main
part of the leaf
is made of-- but the
veins of the leaf
are the five metals from
the Ehrlich Simon bet
so it's sort of just the
symbolic power of the bet
itself.
But I think that
story of Simon wins,
Ehrlich loses is too simple
an interpretation of this bet
and of the larger clash
between Ehrlich and Simon.
Because while measures
of human welfare
have improved in recent
decades, the planet's ecosystems
are also under more
stress than ever before.
You have global
temperatures rising,
fish stocks being depleted.
And the quest to meet the
resource demands to avoid
facing scarcity have pushed
us into more and more risky
practices, from blowing up
the mountains of Appalachia
in mountaintop removal mining
or going out into deep water oil
drilling leading to the
disastrous spill that
took place in the
Gulf, a whole variety
of different challenges-- risks
that we're taking in order
to avoid the scarcity that
Ehrlich like was warning of.
Ehrlich and his
allies have insisted
that the bet doesn't
prove anything.
He says Julian Simon is like
the guy who jumps off the Empire
State Building and says
how great everything is
as he passes the 10th floor
of the building going down.
So Simon's actual
victory of the bet
also has come under
attack because economists
have gone back and
they have charted
the prices of metals
going back to 1900.
And they found that
actually if you
were to run this bet in
1900 to 1910, 1901 to 1911,
Ehrlich actually would
have won more times
than he would have lost.
So the idea that Simon's
victory between 1980 1990
symbolizes that
prices of resources
are always going
to go down, that's
actually not borne out over
the course of this history.
But this data,
though, also, I think,
is complicated because it
doesn't show either a clear
rise or a clear drop
over the period of time.
And, in fact, most
of the reasons
why Ehrlich would have
won over this time period
is the recovery from
the tremendous collapse
in commodity prices after World
War I and then, eventually,
the recovery of those prices.
I think what it
suggests most of all
is how unreliable
commodity prices are
as a proxy for trying to
assess either the well
being of humanity or the state
of the planet's ecosystems.
So instead of being a
simple morality tale,
I think that the story of
Ehrlich and Simon's bet
reveals limitations
on both sides
of the environmental debate.
And I think the stark
framing that both men
chose has made a
productive conversation
about environmental problems
even more difficult.
And rather than choose between
these competing perspectives,
what I think that
we need to do is
to wrestle with the tensions
and the uncertainties
that they raise and to try to
gain from the insights that
come from both the
economic side and also
the insights of the biologists.
So I wanted to close
with a few lessons
that I think each side of this
conversation might take away.
One of the main lessons for
environmentalists from the bet,
I think, is the power of human
adaptability and creativity.
So environmentalists
have often been
prone to these kinds of
pessimistic predictions
about the terrible catastrophe
there's right around the corner
if we don't take action.
That has been the rhetoric of
many like Ehrlich since 1960s
or you could say it even
goes back further to people
like Malthus much earlier.
But I think that
this clearly has not
been the case in recent times.
And I think that the
environmental community
has to figure out how to
wrestle with that contradiction
of the disaster not
having come yet.
And what does that
mean for how we
think about
environmental problems?
And these sweeping apocalyptic
pronouncements themselves
also carry risks
because they make
it more difficult to achieve
pragmatic policy making.
If you're warning of
the end of civilization,
it makes it very hard to come
up with a pragmatic solution
around emissions trading,
around pollution credits,
for instance, things like that.
And I think that the
dire rhetoric also
makes it very difficult
for the followers of people
like Ehrlich to be willing
to accept compromise
and to be willing
to-- it creates
unrealistic expectations
of what policies are going
to accomplish in a
short period of time.
The second inside I think
for the environmental side
of this debate is
the way in which
the debate itself--
overpopulation growth
and resource scarcity-- has
a legacy and it matters.
Because a lot of the
skepticism towards climate
change that you
see today I think
is fueled in part by the
legacy of these past debates
over resource scarcity
and population growth.
And people say,
look, Ehrlich was
wrong about the predictions.
"The Limits of Growth,"
they were wrong.
They said we were
going to run out
of all these things by
all these previous dates.
We didn't run out
of oil in the 1980s.
Pollution's gotten
better rather than worse.
All these different
ways-- predictions
have not come true as were
expected or were predicted.
And so therefore we're now going
to doubt these new predictions.
So there's a lack
of credibility.
And I think that,
for environmentalists
to understand the people who
they call climate deniers,
I think it's useful to
wrestle with this history,
these debates over and kind of
to think a little bit more--
again the empathy
that I was talking
about the beginning of the talk,
of trying to understand why you
would see such skepticism
around the science.
And I'm not saying that's the
only reason for skepticism.
There are many factors
going on but I believe
that wrestling with this
history of this debate
is really-- has an impact
on our debate today.
So now for conservative
followers of Julian Simon,
I think there are also
important lessons, one of which
is just that past success is not
a guarantee of future success.
And I think this often is
not adequately appreciated,
that our ability to adapt to
greater numbers of people,
our ability to find
new energy resources,
those don't necessarily
mean that we
are going to be able
to find solutions
to the threat of climate change.
And so just to assume that just
because we solved something
in the past doesn't
mean we're going
to solve it in the future.
And I think that extends
to the second insight which
is that climate change is
different from population
growth.
These aren't the same problems.
And so to say that we addressed
the growth of population,
we were able to meet the
needs of growing population
doesn't necessarily have
similar implications for climate
change.
Climate change is a
very specific problem.
We're putting too much
of too many chemicals
in the atmosphere.
In my view, it's a
pollution problem.
Whereas population growth
is a very diffuse issue.
There's many different
ways to feed people,
to meet their energy needs, to
adapt to the diffuse pressures
that more people put
on land and resources.
And those are in the marketplace
because people are out there
trying to consume things
and they're making demands
and the marketplace
responds to those demands.
And so the forces that
Julian Simon talked about,
these market forces, can
respond to population growth.
Whereas climate change
is, by very definition,
it's outside of the marketplace
or it has been today.
And until it is brought
within the marketplace,
those kinds of forces that
Simon's followers love to tout
aren't really being brought
to bear on the problem.
And that brings me
to the third insight
I think that should be
shared with Simon's followers
which is that you
can't solve problems
unless you acknowledge them.
So Julian Simon in
that video I shared
made the case that
problems rise up,
we create solutions
to those problems,
and then we're better
off than before.
But that's only if you
recognize that a problem exists.
Because if you don't recognize
that a problem like climate
change exists, then you're not
bringing any of these forces
to bear on solving the problem.
And all of the science and
technology and innovation
that may very well be able to
address the problem of climate
change are not being
brought into play.
And so I think that this is one
of the fundamental limitations,
I think, of the
Simon perspective,
which is that the very optimism
about the future itself
becomes an inhibiting the
bringing about of that future
because an obstacle
to innovation.
So now I want to return to my
first themes about listening
and empathy and
complexity and questions,
the kinds of learning I think
that history has to offer.
Because I think too often,
on both sides of this debate,
both sides of this
debate have not
been willing to
listen to each other.
Ehrlich has bluntly
stated, including recently
in discussion of the
bet in an interview,
that there's nothing to
learn from this story other
than that it's a bad
idea to make bets.
It was ill advised but he says
that it doesn't necessarily
signify anything about what's
happening in the future.
And on the other hand,
Simon's followers
act as if winning
this 10 year bet
signifies you're always
going to win the bet.
There will never
be any problems.
We're going to solve
all the problems.
And just because we
solved things in the past,
no problems are going to come
up that we can't address.
So I think both
of these positions
are simplistic and wrong.
And that rather than
embrace either Ehrlich
or Simon, what we
need to do is try
to learn from their
insights, learn
from both the tremendous
capacity for human adaptability
and innovation, which Simon
I think give us insights
into, and also the fragility
of the planet and the ways
in which humans are transforming
the planet in more and more
intense ways and
try to figure out
how do we reconcile
and incorporate
these different things into a
coherent vision of the future.
That's really I
believe what history
has to offer in part is
this capacity for synthesis.
And I think that, ultimately,
neither biology nor economics
have the definitive answers
because, if you take
the logic of these two men,
humans might survive along
the lines of Simon and we
might even prosper economically
and in our health
while we also transform
the planet in many of the ways
that Ehrlich has predicted.
So one of the
questions may be, then,
do we want to live in
a more biologically
impoverished planet but more
economically productive planet?
So both these things could be
happening at the same time.
So one lesson I think
from my story here
is that humanities
course ultimately
is going to be determined
less by the iron
laws of nature that
Ehrlich liked to celebrate
or the unbounded market powers
that Simon embraced and more
by the social and political
choices that we have to make.
And what we're faced
with is not a question
of biology or economics in
looking into the future,
but it's really
a social question
about what kind of planet
do we want to live in.
And that, I think, is a
fundamentally an ethical
question, and
that's really what I
hope that we need to
take away from this story
is how to wrestle
with that question
and bring it back and take any
insights from Ehrlich and Simon
to address those issues.
So thank you very
much for listening,
and happy to take any
questions that you might
have about this
about this subject.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: It seems a
little ironic to me
that one of the things
that made the solution
to this particular
question about population
actually is the source of
the next problem we have.
The incredible increase in
use of energy in the planet
helped with a lot
of things that made
it possible to feed, clothe,
and otherwise equip a larger
population because energy
has played a role everywhere.
I mean, we turn energy
into food in this country.
And so it's very interesting
that the solution
to an argument between
two people about two
different points of view creates
a new type of problem for which
neither of their arguments
actually applies all that well
and yet it looks
kind of similar.
PAUL SABIN: Right.
I think that's a good point.
And you're right to
point energy as being
the key element in a lot of ways
in thinking about the future.
Because energy is-- even
we think about water
as being a key issue, but energy
is the key behind desalination
issues, for instance, to
what extent that is viable.
So I think you're right.
So there are actually
three bets in my book.
So one is the little
bet about metal prices,
the second is the bet on
the Carter Reagan election,
but the third bet is the
bet about the future.
And so it's really a
grand historical question.
So are we coming to the
end of an age, fueled
in part by abundant
sources of energy
and our dependence
on fossil fuels,
which is what
Ehrlich would argue--
we're coming to
the end of the boom
and we're going to hit the crash
and this can't be sustained--
or is this a path that we
can continue into the future?
And I think that there
are interesting arguments
on both sides of that
question in terms
of how-- and the technology,
it's uncertain about how
the technology is going to
unfold in terms pf to what
extent we're going be able to
move away from fossil fuels
to find sufficient other energy
sources to meet our needs.
AUDIENCE: I see the radically
different views of these men
and how they've affected our
political discourse and vice
versa.
I read the Club of Rome
Report, "Limits to Growth,"
and all of that and scared the
hell out of me a long time ago.
Do you see a way that we can
bring our political discourse
in this country and worldwide
to a more cooperative way
of addressing problems rather
than being diametrically
opposed?
Dianne Feinstein versus
the senator from Oklahoma.
They're never going to
get together, but how can
we move in that
direction of cooperation,
focusing on solutions?
Well that's a difficult
question and is really
a fundamental
question of the day.
I mean, as a historian,
one of my hopes
is to contribute
to that by sharing
this history of the
past debate in the hopes
that people can find
their way towards a more
productive conversation and be
able to listen to each other
better.
But I think that
that's very optimistic
to think that a book
is going to do that.
My own feeling about the
current state of affairs
is that we're in a
specific moment in time.
And I really am actually
optimistic that we will not
be stuck in this
deadlock forever.
My own feeling is that political
sentiment and popular sentiment
around the question of climate
at some point will break.
And at that point, it will move
into a pragmatic conversation
around adaptation,
around different kinds
of policies, pros and cons
of different strategies
and approaches that
will be more productive.
Not to say that it's
ever going to become easy
but that it will be a more
pragmatic conversation, that we
won't be stuck in this
particular moment.
I don't feel that the current
political constellation
is tenable as a
permanent status quo.
Both the resistance to
the science of climate
and resistance to
the ways in which
it appears that the
climate is changing
around us and the change
over generations of people
and the different
ideas-- so I'm actually
cautiously optimistic
that things will change.
Whether it will
change in time for us
to make a significant impact
on carbon emissions is unclear.
But I have optimism actually
about the political debate
to some extent, modest optimism.
Thanks so much for coming.
[APPLAUSE]